kommt der lockdown noch vor weihnachten
immer mehr bundesländer ziehen die
korona notbremse ein klimaziel mit luft
nach oben 55 prozent weniger
treibhausgase will die eu bis 2030
ausstoßen umweltverbänden ist das zu
wenig und skiflieger auf siegeskurs bei
der weltmeisterschaft liegt karl geiger
überraschend vorn und greift nach dem
titel
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers in allen einen guten
freitag abend und danke dass sie bei uns
sind katja hat nachher den sport in der
sendung und wünscht auch einen schönen
guten abend das wort lockdown ist in
aller munde immer mehr politiker fordern
ihn immer mehr auch sofort also noch
deutlich vor weihnachten
grundlage sind die korona zahlen die
weiter sprunghaft steigen
die maßnahmen der politik haben die lage
bisher nicht verbessert
das robert koch institut meldet auch
heute wieder so viele neue infektionen
wie noch nie in dieser pandemie 29.000
875 fälle sind innerhalb von 24 stunden
registriert worden
das sind 6426 mehr als vor einer woche
und 5 198 menschen sind an oder in
verbindung mit cupid 19 gestorben auch
das ist ein neuer höchstwert
was daraus für die politik folgt in ganz
deutschland und in den einzelnen
bundesländern zeigt an seinem stern
es ist der tag der appelle in
deutschland harte maßnahmen müssten her
fürs ganze land heißt es aus der
bundespolitik und aus fast allen
bundesländern in fast wortgleichen
mahnungen und warnungen so schnell wie
möglich so konsequent wie möglich so
schnell wie möglich besser früher als
später baden württemberg verkündet heute
neue strenge regeln sie gelten schon ab
morgen dazu gehört etwa eine
ausgangssperre in der nacht von 20 bis 5
uhr und auch tagsüber solle man doch
möglichst daheim bleiben
leute bleibt zu hause es sei denn ihr
müsst etwas erledigen das wichtig ist
dringlichkeit wegen stark steigender
zahlen auch in sachsen
hier müssen schulen und viele geschäfte
bereits ab montag dicht machen harte
entscheidungen hier weniger harte
woanders länder regel unterschiede
kritisiert von den ländern selbst wir
spüren es läuft uns davon ist zerrinnt
uns zwischen den fingern wir müssen eine
klarere
konsequentere damit auch verständlichere
entscheidung für alle fälle ich hoffe
dass wir jetzt eine gemeinsame schalter
haben mit allen bundesländern und auch
der kanzlerin und uns dort schnell und
zügig einigen
ab wann dieser shutdown gilt ich glaube
ab weihnachten ist zu spät wir brauchen
ein neues datum
wir können nicht mehr warten wir
brauchen schnellstmöglich einen lock
down in ganz deutschland in ganz
deutschland alle geschäfte zu außer
supermärkte noch vor heiligabend bis
weit in den januar
das wird immer wahrscheinlicher und auch
beim thema schule könnten neue
bundesweite einschränkungen kommen
beschlossen ist von alldem noch nichts
was hier für unverständnis sorgt auf den
intensivstationen unverantwortlich sei
es zu zögern und zu warten das sagen die
notfallmediziner intensivmedizin ist
doch menschlich dass den menschen wieder
arbeiten und ihr können schon jetzt
nicht mehr und diese botschaft muss
jetzt einfach ankommen wird sind das ist
unausweichlich dass wir jetzt ruhe hier
finden dann ruhe in das system
einbringen und die infektionszahlen
wieder richtig runter fahren runter
fahren muss man dafür das land
vermutlich am wochenende soll der
nächste virus gipfel der politik
entscheiden
auch heute abend wieder in der sendung
theo koll in berlin genannt theo manche
bundesländer machen ja jetzt bereits
strengere regeln in eigenregie
was könnte denn ein neues treffen des
bundes mit den ländern da konkret und
zusätzlich bringen
na ja vor allem natürlich
einheitlichkeit im moment erleben wir
doch schon wieder die ganze bandbreite
föderale vielfalt von noch keine
weiteren maßnahmen beschließen bis hin
zu nächtlichen ausgangssperren und
ausgangs beschränkungen ab morgen oder
am montag also ein neuerliches treffen
könnte für die bürger klarheit bringen
und es würde natürlich auch vermeiden
helfen dass beispielsweise die sachsen
dann am montag wenn in ihrem land viele
leben geschlossen werden über die
landesgrenze fahren und im nachbar
bundesland einkaufen und es könnte für
die von schließungen betroffenen auch
klarheit bringen wie viel der
verdienstausfälle wer eigentlich
übernimmt theo das einigermaßen absurde
ist ja dass jetzt immer mehr politiker
schnelles handeln fordern aber wir zwei
zum beispiel die gesamte woche hier
darüber reden wann es denn nun ein neues
bund länder treffen geben wird und bei
alledem ja dann irgendwie auch noch die
gesamte bevölkerung mitgenommen werden
muss wie soll denn das funktionieren
also ehrlich gesagt muss ich sagen ist
es massives politisches versagen dass
ich das ganze land jetzt schon seit
tagen mit der frage von weiteren
verschärfungen beschäftigen muss und das
alles bei täglich schlimmer werden
infektions und todeszahlen die politik
hatte über wochen diesen emotionalen
fixstern weihnachten aufgebaut dann
dürfen wir uns entspannen dann ist
corona heile welt aber seit tagen ist
längst allen verantwortlichen ja klar
dass das prinzip hoffnung dieses
leichten lockt uns versagt hat und nur
noch das prinzip strenge schlimmstes
verhindern kann und dennoch bietet sich
seit tagen eine art wirrwarr ich
befürchte im moment wird vertrauen in
kluges regierungshandeln nicht gerade
gesteigert
die einschätzung von theo koll zdf
berlin theo vielen dank ja und dann
bleibt die große frage woran genau liegt
es dass sich die situation weiter
verschlechtert dass die regeln bislang
so wenig genutzt haben
in den blickpunkt rücken wieder die
verwundbarsten menschen in dieser
pandemie in deutschen pflege und
altersheimen die seit monaten bereits
etwa durch flächendeckende tests besser
geschützt sein sollten eigentlich denn
tatsächlich ist die situation vielerorts
alarmierend pablo silaghi berichtet
trotz teil lockdown explodieren die
korona zahlen also weiter besorgt
registrieren experten betroffen sind
zunehmend die älteren
wir sehen immer mehr ausbrüche in alten-
und pflegeheim es gelingt immer seltener
das virus aus diesen einrichtungen
herauszuhalten
das altenheim st franziskus im
bayerischen kolbermoor
hier achtet man streng darauf alle
vorkehrungen einzuhalten aber auch hier
sterben menschen an und mit kidd 19
durch die unkontrollierte ausbreitung
jetzt in der gesellschaft gibt es halt
einfach viele menschen die nicht wissen
dass sie positiv sind und dann ins
pflegeheim gehen und da gibt es dann
vielleicht auch manchmal nicht in
entsprechende schutzkleidung die man
sich wünschen würde nicht jeder ältere
mensch kann sich eine ft2 maske leisten
um sich selbst auch zu schützen und der
der reingeht der weisheit nicht dass er
positiv ist
um genau dieses problem zu lösen hat die
bundesregierung schon mitte oktober
beschlossen antigen schnelltests für
altenheime flächendeckend zur verfügung
zu stellen
aber bei der umsetzung gibt es
erhebliche schwierigkeiten
jetzt gibt es ja die schnelltests die
grundsätzlich ein gutes mittel sind aber
diese aufgabenbereich wird wieder auf
die einrichtungen abgewälzt und es ist
sehr sehr aufwendig die mitarbeitenden
oder die bewohner oder auch besucher
wenn wir die alle oft testen müssen dann
ist es ein riesiger arbeitsaufwand ja
noch oben drauf kommt tübingen in baden
württemberg setzt auf einen besonderen
schutz der älteren
dort gab es nach angaben der stadt
zuletzt keine corona fälle mehr
bei menschen über 75 jahren die stadt
bietet senioren verbilligte taxifahrten
am um busfahrten zu vermeiden
supermärkte sind in der zeit von 9 bis
11 älteren kunden vorbehalten
außerdem wird in alten und pflegeheimen
konsequent getestet der erfolg der
maßnahmen in tübingen könnte als vorbild
für ganz deutschland ihnen jede kommune
kann selbst entscheiden
in den deutschen einkaufsstraßen ist
jetzt die wichtigste zeit des jahres
shopping vor dem fest und gleichzeitig
ist alles anders
es gelten ja bereits viele regeln die
frage ist ob sie auch eingehalten werden
und es wird immer klarer möglicherweise
müssen die allermeisten geschäfte bald
schließen um die infektionszahlen unter
kontrolle zu bringen
eva schiller ist auf der königstraße in
stuttgart der angeblich längsten
fußgängerzone europas hallo eva wie
gehen denn die leute mit den aussichten
um ziemlich große verwirrung was die
regelungen angeht hier hinter mir wurde
erst heute ein neuer glühweinstand
aufgebaut kaufen dürfen die menschen den
glühwein am stand trinken aber nicht
dafür müssen sie 100 meter weiter gehen
da sagen viele das ist wirklich nicht
mehr nachvollziehbar und ähnliches gilt
auch für diese ausgangs beschränkungen
die ab morgen gelten sollen
einkaufen ist weiter ein triftiger grund
um rauszugehen weihnachtsshopping will
man aber verhindern dann ist der kleber
inzwischen durch verboten
viele haben mir wirklich gesagt wir
verstehen das alles nicht mehr wir
wünschen uns mehr klarheit und es ist
auch wirklich so dass die meisten gesagt
haben lieber jetzt ein schneller harter
lockdown als weiter diese scheibchen
taktik und mein eindruck ist auch viele
einzelhändler haben sich eigentlich
schon ihrem schicksal gefügt die rechnen
damit dass die ab nächster woche dicht
machen müssen da wird aber natürlich
auch gleich der ruf nach hilfen laut
viel unklarheit also und viel trubel
gleichzeitig auch stuttgarts
haupteinkaufsstraße hersteller vielen
herzlichen dank
durch die korona pandemie sind im
november deutlich mehr menschen
gestorben als im schnitt der letzten
jahre
mehr zu dieser über sterblichkeit dieser
sogenannten über sterblichkeit mit
zahlen des statistischen bundesamtes
finden sie in unserer zdf heute app
welche wirklich dramatischen folgen
dieser pandemie eben auch hat das zeigt
sich gerade in den usa dort stecken sich
nach den offiziellen zahlen aktuell fast
200 32.000 menschen an und 3411 sind
gestorben
an einem einzigen tag und dazu kommt in
der wirtschafts nation nummer eins auf
der
mit diesem so reichen land das hier
immer mehr menschen verlieren ihren job
verlieren ihr zuhause verlieren ihre
krankenversicherung und sie hungern 50
millionen menschen haben in den usa
derzeit nicht genug zu essen schätzen
hilfsorganisationen viele davon wegen
der pandemie aus washington britta jäger
kurz bevor corona kam hat der angel ak
nie gerade erst wieder angefangen zu
arbeiten
55.000 dollar jahreseinkommen für sich
und die drei kinder endlich der umzug in
ein größeres heim
nun ist die arbeitslosigkeit wieder
zurück und mit ihr die verzweiflung wie
bloß rechnungen miete und lebensmittel
bezahlen
ich habe den kindern versprochen dass
sie endlich ein normales leben führen
können dann traf uns die pandemie jetzt
muss sich die rechnungen hochwerfen und
die greifen deren betrag ich hoffentlich
noch aufbringen kann
landesweit kilometer lange schlangen an
den essensausgaben etwa 50 millionen
amerikaner sind von hunger bedroht
geringverdiener wie arbeitslose die
waren durch eine erhöhung des
arbeitslosengeldes aus dem ersten
hilfspaket im frühling noch über die
runden gekommen
doch die hilfen liefen längst aus es
gibt einfach so viele menschen die
kämpfen müssen sie haben angst vor der
me2 und machen sich sorgen um all ihre
grund ausgaben und sie haben einfach
kein geld um satt zu werden
ein neues hilfspaket in der krise
brauchen die usa dringend doch
republikaner und demokraten in
washington streiten seit monaten
erbittert um die bedingungen eine
einigung ist nicht in sicht obwohl zum
jahresende weitere hilfen auslaufen dann
wären angel akw und millionen weitere
amerikaner etwa nicht mehr vor
zwangsräumungen geschützt sie alle
könnten dann auf der straße landen
unser nächstes thema eu gipfel in
brüssel eine ganze reihe schwieriger
probleme auf der tagesordnung und jetzt
auch eine ganze reihe wichtiger
beschlüsse gucken wir uns an was die
staats und regierungschefs darauf den
weg gebracht haben gestern schon den
billionenschweren haushalt
außerdem einen kompromiss beim streit
über die rechtsstaatlichkeit der eu und
auch abgesegnet die korona hilfen und
heute früh kam noch ein wichtiger
schritt dazu bei den zielen die sich
europa steckt zur klimarettung stefan
leifert wenn vom gipfel fotos mit
kaffeetassen getwittert werden weiß man
die nacht war lang 21 stunden gipfel und
keine stunde schlaf liegen hinter der
kanzlerin als es am morgen durchbrüche
zu verkünden gibt vor allem beim klima
die eu schraubt nach quellen der debatte
ihre ziele hoch dafür hat es sich auch
gelohnt eine nacht nicht zu schlafen
ich möchte mir nicht ausmalen was
gewesen wäre wenn wir ein solches
ergebnis nicht hätten erreichen können
zudem an putz die einigung von heute
bringt uns auf einen klaren weg in
richtung klimaneutralität bis 2050 es
gibt den investoren den unternehmen den
verwaltungen und den bürgern sicherheit
die citizens die eu gibt sich neue
klimaziele stadt und 40 sollen die
treibhausgase bis 2030 um 55 prozent
sinken
die eu bleibt beim ziel bis 2050
klimaneutral zu sein ein zugeständnis
baut ein land co2 durch aufforstung oder
neue technologie ab ist das anrechenbare
vor allem polen mit seiner hohen kohle
quote kämpfte um finanzielle zusagen und
flexiblere ziele
nach stunden des ringens stimmt
premierminister morawetz geht zu weit
den klima beschluss aber auf den
klimaschutz jetzt wirklich dennoch beim
letzten gipfel des jahres räumt die eu
große brocken weg die deutsche
ratspräsidentschaft endet mit
erleichterung dieser tag aber vor allem
mit erschöpfung so stefan dann machen
wir doch jetzt mal einen strich drunter
nach einem halben jahr deutscher
ratspräsidentschaft wie viel besser
steht die eu jetzt da sagen wir mal so
sie steht vor allem nicht schlechter da
und das ist angesichts der historischen
krise die die eu im moment durch macht
vielleicht der größte erfolg dieser
ratspräsidentschaft
es ist diesem letzten gipfel des jahres
lungen alle pflicht themen abzuräumen
die noch offen waren neben dem klima der
haushalt die frage der
rechtsstaatlichkeit die korona hilfen
wenn man sich vor augen hält dass all
diese themen vor ein paar tagen noch auf
der kippe standen und auch hätten
scheitern können wirklich ein erfolg
hier hat sich die deutsche rats
präsidentschaft als kompromiss maschine
erwiesen was auf der strecke geblieben
ist das ist zum einen die große frage
der migration und zum anderen die
neuausrichtung der europäischen
außenpolitik vor allem im hinblick auf
china das erben jetzt als themen die
portugiesen die als nächstes mit der
ratspräsidentschaft dran sind
angesichts der großen krisen der letzten
monate muss man für die deutsche
ratspräsidentschaft sagen angela merkel
hat sich hier als erfahrene
krisenmanagerin profiliert und bewährt
große eu visionen hat sie nicht
entworfen die waren allerdings im
letzten halben jahr auch nicht so
richtig gefragt stefan leifels live aus
brüssel heute abend vielen dank einigung
der eu bei den klimazielen also doch
ziele also das eine die umsetzung das
andere klar gemacht haben dass heute
freude ist future anhänger wie hier in
berlin erinnerten aktivisten in mehreren
städten an das klimaabkommen von paris
von vor fünf jahren
sie bemängeln dass das damals
vereinbarte ziel noch lange nicht
erreicht ist nämlich die erderwärmung
auf 1,5 grad zu begrenzen
derzeit steuert die welt er auf drei
grad zu straftäter und gefährde die aus
syrien kommen sollen künftig wieder in
ihre heimat abgeschoben werden die
innenminister der länder haben den seit
2012 geltenden abschiebestopp nicht
verlängert
thema bei der innenministerkonferenz war
auch die afd
verfassungsschutz präsident thomas
haldenwang berichtete den ministern eine
beobachtung der partei durch seine
behörde rücke näher
das erfuhr das zdf hauptstadtstudio mehr
dazu von nicole diekmann eine rechte
bloggerin bedrängt und beleidigt im
bundeswirtschaftsminister im reichstag
zu gast im hohen haus ist sie auf
einladung eines afd abgeordneten diese
episode sorgte für viel ärger und für
gespräche auf der innenministerkonferenz
dieses thema haben wir miteinander
gesprochen
ob es gegebenenfalls bestrebungen gibt
die demokratie von innen auf
parlamentarischem wege auszuhöhlen afd
parteitag vor zwei wochen streit über
die reichstags episode und über eine
zusammenarbeit mit der querdenker
bewegung die auseinandersetzung zum teil
erbittert ist das eine trendwende oder
es ist ein letztes aufbäumen der
gemäßigten kräfte ich habe wenig
anhaltspunkte dafür dass das er in die
mitte der gesellschaft zurückgeht
sondern eher nach rechts aussen laut zdf
informationen berichtete gestern der
präsident des bundesverfassungsschutzes
an die innenminister im januar weil er
seinen dienst bekannt geben ob er die
gesamte afd beobachtet vieles deutet
darauf hin heißt das zweites großes
thema der innenminister der
abschiebestopp für straftäter und
gefährde aus syrien wird nicht
verlängert
das heißt dass jede diskussion stehende
abschiebung im einzelfall konkret
geprüft wird wie sie möglich ist wie sie
vertretbar ist darüber offener streit
zwischen union und spd
ich halte das auch ein stück weit für
populistisch auch wir finden es
entsetzlich dass hier menschen schutz
finden und nicht abgeschoben werden
dürfen
aber wir leben in einer zeit gott sei
dank in einer zeit in der das prinzip
auge um auge nicht gilt es keine
einigung damit läuft der abschiebestopp
ende des jahres aus das war auch der
wunsch von bundesinnenminister seehofer
er fehlte heute
er befindet sich in quarantäne ein jahr
lang lag der bau der deutsch russischen
ostseepipeline nord stream 2 brach seit
heute gehen die arbeiten weiter
wie der betreiber mitteilte werde ein
2,6 kilometer langer leitungsabschnitt
verlegt die us-regierung lehnt den bau
von nord stream 2 entschieden ab weil
damit künftig noch mehr russisches
erdgas nach deutschland transportiert
werden soll
seit einem jahr droht washington mit
sanktionen gegen firmen die an dem
projekt beteiligt sind
und damit sind wir in dieser sendung
beim winter hat ja und es läuft wobei
eigentlich muss man sagen es fliegt denn
viel besser hätte der auftakt der
skiflug wm in planica slowenien für die
dsv athlet nicht laufen können
nach dem ersten tag und nach zwei von
vier sprüngen führt karl geiger die
konkurrenz an
markus eisenbichler ist dritter markus
eisenbichler bringt es auf den punkt
teamkollege karl geiger als wettkampf
typ bekannt zeigt schon im ersten
durchgang das in diese schanze in
planica liegt 245 einhalb meter die
führung gibt ja auch im zweiten
durchgang nicht mehr ab der tag ich
hätte mir nicht erträumt er sich nach
der halbzeit für markus eisenbichler
steigert sich im laufe des wettkampfs
mit dem zweiten sprung auf 247 meter
belegt er nach den beiden ersten wm
durchgängen rang drei hinter geiger und
dem norweger group gute voraussetzungen
für die titelentscheidung morgen und das
übertragen wir live im zdf der lange
winter sport tag beginnt um 10 uhr 20
dann auch wieder mit biathlon aus
hochfilzen benedikt doll und ihre gläser
sprinteten heute schon in die top ten
und biathletin franziska preuß sogar
aufs treppchen
zufriedenheit ist ein hohes gut in
diesen tagen und franziska preuß scheint
heute nach ihrem dritten platz im sprint
sehr zufrieden zu sein
wir geben richtig günstig zeitlauf und
dann ist mir nicht egal jetzt 203 eck
die beste des tages dinara lembecker war
aus belarus überzeugt nicht nur am
schießstand mit zehn treffern sondern
auch auf der strecke
franziska preuß hingegen leistet sich
eine strafrunde verliert am ende den
zweiten platz an die laufschnellste aus
norwegen
thierry lacoste nun ist er da in der
formel 1 mit schumacher der 21-jährige
nahmen heute erstmals platz im hs
ferrari fuhr im freien training zum
großen preis von abu dhabi seine ersten
runden und die 18 schnellste zeit das
rennen fährt dann wieder stammpilot
kevin magnussen aber in der kommenden
saison hat nick schumacher das cockpit
dann beim haas team sicher danke katja
bitteschön gern geschehen
und jetzt noch dass weihnachtskrippen
gehören ja traditionell zum fest dazu
aber müssen sie deshalb auch gleich
immer gleich aussehen
nein zeigt uns ausgerechnet der
traditionsbewusste vatikan
dort ist heute abend die krippe zum fest
feierlich enthüllt worden und die
besticht diesmal mit wuchtiger keramik
kunst sagen wir mal die
weihnachtsgeschichte neu interpretiert
zum ausgleich dahinter der baum 28 meter
hoch und aufs traditionellste geschmückt
wie schön
passend zur nachrichtenlage in diesen
zeiten das wetter der winter zeigt sich
derzeit von seiner schmuddeligen seite
und das bleibt auch am dritten
adventswochenende so alle details gleich
von katja honnefer das heute schon mal
mit der kollegin marietta slomka um 22
uhr am wochenende freut sich barbara
hahlweg hier auf sie wir sehen uns am
montag wieder vom gesamten team danke
für ihr großes interesse und ich wünsche
ihnen ein sehr angenehmer abend
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren das tief an
dieser beschäftigt uns jetzt am dritten
adventswochenende
es bringt viele wolken mit und
anfänglich auch noch ein bisschen
gefrierenden regen oder schnee später
dann nur noch regen und vor allen dingen
milde luft heute nacht kann es daher
gefährlich seien nämlich an der grenze
zur kälte da kann es nämlich gefährlich
glaubt werden auf den straßen wir
ungefähr zwischen der rhön und dem
bodensee im osten ist es zum teil klar
und an der donau bildet sich auch mal
nebel
die temperaturen sinken in der osthälfte
auf 0 bis minus 3 grad im westen bleibt
ist bilder bei 5 bis 1 grad
und diese temperaturverteilung zeigt
sich morgen auch über tag also auch da
ist es dann dem osten am kühlsten mit 1
bis 5 grad im westen wird es dagegen
richtig mild und wieder rein klettern
die werte bis 9 grad
das wird allerdings ein sehr trübe
adventssamstag die sonne bleibt auf
tauchstation und vor allen dingen im
westen kann es auch mal leicht regnen
der sonntag wird kaum anders aber ab
montag setzt sich doch zumindest in
süddeutschland hier und da auch mal die
sonne durch und die temperaturen werden
steigen auf 2 bis 12 grad